Billy wrote in saying hey do you guys
eat food that's past its expiration date
if it still smells and looks fine I have
I have some pretty specific thoughts on
this milk is an interesting one and I
think there's also confusion between the
best buy and sell by dates a lot of
people don't seem to understand that
concept if you open something up that
has a best buy date that might be months
away once it's open it might only last a
week and I think I have friends who seem
to still not understand this even though
they're in their late 20s or early 30s
which is interesting I will just make it
a case-by-case decision when it comes to
something like meat which I really don't
eat much of I will basically try to buy
it cook it and eat it within a few days
obviously if I've made chicken for the
week I'm fine
five or six days later eating the
chicken if it's been properly
refrigerated and that's not not so much
an expiration date when it comes to
canned food I never have really
experimented with expired canned food
because mostly I buy things that I'm
gonna use pretty soon black beans or
whatever so I would probably although I
know that there's a whole industry
around expiration and it applies all
sort of big pharma and pharmaceuticals
and expiration dates on things like
advil which are probably good for a very
very long time past their expiration
date I probably wouldn't tempt fate by
going too far beyond the expiration date
yeah I have a zero-tolerance policy when
it comes to eating and drinking foods
that are past their expiration date
really even if it's maybe a couple days
before I'll just throw it away
what about dry pasta um you know pasta I
mean that should be fine but I'm
thinking more about things that you
refrigerate yeah and at that point I'll
give it the smell test and if it doesn't
pass the smell test I'm certainly not
gonna eat it for me the thing is most of
the foods where I make a call about
whether I need to throw it out instead
of eating it and I hate throwing food
out they aren't the foods that have an
expiration date printed on them it's
things like fruits vegetables meat and
and dairy some of which has expiration
dates and the smell test is really the
thing and I've had milk that after three
days I smell it and it's not good and I
get rid of it and I've had milk that for
example when I went to London at the end
of the year I had opened milk on the
let's see I left on the turn I think I
had open milk on the 22nd I got back on
the 30th and on the 31st I opened the
milk and it smelled fine and I drank the
milk and it was no big deal
even though normally you'd say milk open
for nine days or something like that I
don't know about that yeah I think it's
reaching the end of its lifespan there
but now that you've brought up fruits I
think that's one of my exceptions
because if a fruit is is quite bruised I
think that kind of adds to the flavor
and I won't eat a banana until it's
quite brown until the whole banana has
brown spots on a Saturday if it's even
so Brown I'll just blend it up
vegan Pat destroying rotten bananas Wow
that is the headline that we're going to
be seeing I think on reddit tomorrow
yeah I mean ten bananas at a time
sometimes you went from when you were
not vegan Pat told me he used to eat
five eggs a day now he's at five up to
five bananas a day you got to replace it
it was yellow I mean yeah I know it made
perfect sense okay send me your thoughts
about expiration dates on food